Vamos a defender al unísono
en una ofensiva política,
social y judicial sin cuartel
y sin descanso.
Les anuncio.
He dado indicaciones de que el partido popular
registre esta misma mañana
la solicitud
de comparecencia del Presidente del gobierno
para dar cuenta de los acuerdos firmados ayer con yums.
He pedido a nuestro equipo jurídico que evalúe
hasta la última coma,
en primer lugar,
de los reales decretos leyes y también
de los acuerdos que se han suscrito,
y de las consecuencias de los acuerdos del día de ayer,
para intentar poner coto en los tribunales a cada
decisión adoptada por el señor Sánchez.
En tercer lugar,
haremos que cada
representante político de cada rincón de España
dé su opinión.
Que, por supuesto,
en todos los ayuntamientos y parlamentos autonómicos
se dé opinión de lo que ayer se pactó
de forma clandestina
con un partido político
al objeto de que se abstuviese
o no participase
en las votaciones de los reales decretos leyes.
El próximo 28 de enero volveremos a la calle
en un acto
que concentraremos en Madrid
para decir alto y claro que
a este país no